what does it say about the media I agree
with these the media is corrupt
not all media's look I know some some
great people including you but I know
some great journalists look they
Pulitzer Prizes to people they got it
wrong okay all these people Fortuna from
the New York Times which is a fake
newspaper we don't even want it in the
White House anymore gonna probably
terminate that in The Washington Post
they're fake but you take a look at the
New York Times and you take a look at
the kind of reporting they do it was all
it turned out to be all wrong and after
the election the New York Times
apologized for their coverage because
they were covering me in such a way so
when I won
they actually apologized to their
subscribers because they were losing
thousands and thousands of subscribers
the New York Times wrote an apology
nothing else you know they're saying
well it wasn't really an apology it was
because they covered me so badly and
then what I said sort of interesting I
think I hope I said you know the good
news is now be covered fairly again and
you know what happened I got covered
worse
I get covered worse but that's okay you
know right tomorrow is worse than a they
say Oh
Abraham Lincoln I've heard the one
person used to be five or six now it's
down to one Honest Abe Lincoln they say
you got the worst press of anybody I say
I dispute it let me ask you so now the
Democrats has already jumped out of the
plane can't go back do you see a
scenario where they will impeach you
there'll be a trial in the Senate and
then the people get to speak would that
be the ultimate revenge which is your
reelection if the people speak so
everybody tells me it's going to be
great for us as a Republican party if
they actually impeach me because the 40
seats and there are many more than the
32 which 4045 seats where I won or did
really well or very close that those
people are going to get hammered
meaning running in Congress so I don't
know if that's true or not I do say this
and I can see it because I've been I
mean look at our fundraising the money's
never come in like this look at my poll
numbers have been like the highest I was
in Dallas the other night we set a
record in a stadium I don't know it's
got to be an arena that's got
to be 20 years old we have only layers a
record we had thousands of people
outside watching on big screens they've
never seen anything like that but and
it's that way at every place I mean that
was Dallas which we loved that was great
they did a great job great place but
it's that way every place look at in
Louisiana in Louisiana
the other night a governor was at 66
he couldn't get 50% and now you can ever
run off with a really great Republican
candidate look at North Carolina's great
state great people two races that were
going to be lost I went in made a speech
let everybody know I really respect
these two guys and they're gonna be
great they both won they both won by
good margins they both won so I think
the public is seeing it actually
[Music]